Lonzo ball with an on the shot clock
so racket start offensive man on the
reverse
okay listen do you have member I say
this all the time he is one of them on a
lot of basketball and given the pails
steward for possessions good looked ran
and Ingram's wanted to go inside he will
it'll be Zion what about the adjustment
in Arizona that's Kevin Love taking the
contact and then still having the
strength to finish there's a sweet
finish job around 460 of game of the
paint that serious and true to the
chopper
right here cuz I on snuck behind the
defense lounge opal all the time on
target good finish held by nine on his
hip in the New York Knick game and not
able to go Marant with a finger roll
flip over Millie that's gone by in the
second quarter in an eight-point lead
for shots in the paint in the novel free
throw test do you know but a lot of
these are take angrily jerison Atlanta
wasn't ready board it was hot
Valanciunas is okay in this partner if
he didn't come down his hand but how
about that throw friend look we catch
the ball listen to balls nowhere near
the best look and it's a lob for
midcourt look at that boy listen to
balls nowhere near the best look and
it's a lob for midcourt look at that the
other brunch try to do it inside and
it's almost given away
Brandon Ingram man oh man Senate race
great job by xiah putting this up in the
dunker position and rightly see throughs
turn the corner throw it up I will go
get it
sign leaves the Belles with 14 so far
because the middle taking herself off
the three-point line till he get a full
head of steam the game since he's had
that conversation culture 13th and
defensive efficiency huge improvement
there's brie goes JA more ants over the
triple filling up the boxes usual with
JJ Redick and Josh harden about to check
into the game it's a 91 to the board
already JAMA rant beautiful move and eat
one more coming off for pissed off the
weak side shot Cleveland the game before
at Hope Zion gets there again no power
zone yes
[Applause]
pretty amazing I like this because he's
taking up the space that battle-ax tunis
is leaving him like he is almost like
Valanciunas this daring him to shoot you
know going to beat me from the outside
Josh Hart's got some space a little bit
strong so they're in sync
to lances rapers I'll walk left sixteen
seven did not catch it getting rid of it
go get his eye on 500 career win what an
accomplishment
[Applause]
you know tomorrow's February first we
start Black History Month so bald with
legal belly shot coming down Zion
against Alan Chile's gets to his strong
side man underneath the big guy Game
five
he's got 22 this is not an easy shot